coercive control has been an offense in
the UK since 2015 but what is it is the
law working and how can you spot whether
it's happening to you
under the serious Crimes Act the
following must be true for someone to be
convicted of this offense
that the abuser is personally connected
to the victim their behavior has had a
serious effect on the victim and the
abuser knew or ought to have known that
their behavior would have a serious
effect on you your abuser's behavior is
considered to have a serious effect if
on at least two occasions the victim has
feared that violence will be used
against them or their felt serious alarm
or distress and it has had a substantial
effect on their usual day-to-day
activities before this law the only way
that domestic abusers were convicted was
if they were physically assaulting
victims but coercive controllers far
more subtle than that and more difficult
to spot especially as victims become
further detached from family and friends
the impact of coercive control varies
between victims but a really common
response is post-traumatic stress
disorder this can physically alter the
victim's brain and ability to function
the amygdala which triggers the body's
responses to stress is put on high alert
by the constant abuse and can actively
warp a person's ability to react
rationally and see things clearly
because of the nature of this Crime
Victims themselves might not even know
what's happening to them
here are the key signs that it's
happening to you or someone you know
isolating you from friends and family
monitoring your time spying on your
social media or devices taking control
over aspects of your everyday life such
as where you can go who you can see what
you can wear and when you can sleep
depriving you access to support services
such as Medical Services
repeatedly putting you down such as
saying you're worthless humiliating
degrading or dehumanizing you
controlling your finances making threats
or intimidating you depriving you of
basic needs
[Music]
mental abuse is the most difficult thing
to
explain to people I think that over the
years mine
was like a drip feed coming at me and it
came to a crescendo at the end Sally
Challen had been convicted of murdering
her husband who'd emotionally abused her
for many years she was released in 2019
in the first high-profile case of
coercive control being used as a defense
the court that convicted her wasn't able
to take into account the psychological
effect that being in that sort of
abusive relationship will have had on
her and on her mental state and the
state she was in when she killed her
partner
while her case showed just how powerful
an impact coercive control could have on
victims and how much that new defense
was needed the law hasn't transformed
the justice system in the way that some
campaigners would have wanted the number
of coercive control offenses recorded by
the police increased from
4246 in 12 months across 2016 and 2017
to 24
856 in 12 months across 2019 and 2020.
in 2019 just
1112 defendants were prosecuted for
these offenses a Government Review
acknowledged that the crime is likely to
be far more prevalent but there are
issues in both victims and police
recognizing the crime
I think what is necessary rather than
more legislation is better training for
police of recognizing when the situation
is dangerous and when an offense needs
to be charged
if you want to speak to someone about
the issues we've raised here are some
numbers you can call